melissa's vote goes to
congratulations xavier
you
are the winner
of big brother
that is the moment that xavier prather
made reality tv history as the first
black winner of big brother here on cbs
he won 750 thousand dollars when he
ended the show last week with the big
win prather and five other black house
guests formed a group called the cookout
alliance they worked together to see a
black contested win for the first time
in the show's 21 year history wow let's
take a look at how that alliance was
created in secret
we're here the game brought us here the
game brought up we're here to also
change the culture think about the gear
we just had
the whole black life matter movement
like
it's important for us to be here and
stick together we agree that this is
going to be called the cookout that's
how we do uh-huh all right i like that i
like that
you got to do it for the culture
everybody wants to be invited to the
cookout everybody wants an invite so
xavier prather's joining us right now
good morning first off congratulations
thank you thank you and good morning and
thank you guys for having me i
appreciate it you've had a few days to
kind of process this has it set in yet
that you are 750 thousand dollars richer
um still not quite yet um still haven't
seen it yet but uh it's uh it's it's
starting to set in a little bit more the
more you know press do i do the more
interviews i do the more starting to set
in at what we accomplish um so the wii
in that sentence what was the
significance of the cookout alliance and
how did you block out the other
contestants the significance of the
cookout alliance is that six individuals
who had the same goal and vision in mind
to help big brother crown its first
black winner came together put aside any
differences that they had to achieve the
same goal and throughout the season
that's all we did you know we were we
were strategizing we were scheming
against the other house guests
not necessarily because they weren't
black but simply because that's what you
do in big brother you form an alliance
and then your goal is to get anybody
who's outside of that alliance out of
the house yeah and you want to be the
last man standing absolutely but this is
the thing you're an attorney by trade
yes but you didn't want people to know
what did you tell them that you did um i
told them that i was a model and a
bartender model and things that i
actually do um the bartending i do
pretty infrequently but the modeling i
do part-time why wouldn't you want
people to know you're an attorney um
just to do what i could to minimize my
threat level i felt like if they knew i
was an attorney going into the game i
probably would have been one of the
first ones out yeah so i felt like by
keeping that under wraps it gave me the
best chance to do what i came to do what
does your success and also being an
attorney mean for representation of a
black man in reality tv um i think it's
everything the goal for this season was
representation to show little little
black boys and little black girls like
hey to be successful in society you
don't have to you know be very good a a
very successful athlete or like some
outstanding entertainer you can be or
ratchet or ratchet exactly you don't
have to beat each other up yeah yes you
can be an upstanding
citizen while also making sure you're
staying true to your blackness and i
think that's something that was
important for american society to see
not just in myself but the five other
members of the cookout as well but as
you know i love the i love the cookout
alliance because you're right nate
everybody wants to go the cookout
but
there's of course always chatter online
as there always is the haters are coming
for you saying but isn't this reverse
racism what is your response to that my
response to that would be this this
wasn't reverse racism this was simply
black unity this was five six black
people coming together with a goal in
mind we weren't targeting people
necessarily outside of our race in the
context of the game we came together and
formed an alliance and in this game your
goal is to get out people outside of
that alliance and it was purely that we
we weren't trying to establish any type
of black superiority that's not what we
were doing we were simply playing the
game and i'd say we did it pretty well
yeah i'd say yeah you and you engaged in
strategy that paid off i was surprised
to hear there had never been a black
winner
21 seasons the closest well um to
clarify on the celebrity big brother
edition tamar braxton was the first
black winner and then on big brother
canada desean carter newman was a black
winner as well but i am the first yes
this game yes
i don't get that
on um on season three danielle reyes
made it to the final two chairs and
that's the furthest a black person has
gone on the show so to have six black
people make it to the final six was was
incredible what was it like playing the
game being isolated for it how many days
85 days 85 wow wow you just got out of
that yeah so you know life's a little
different you're re-acclimating catching
up on a few things will you be friends
with it because you didn't know any of
these guys before no not at all but yeah
absolutely i think um what we were able
to accomplish we're all going to be
bonded for life and um yeah those are my
brothers and my sisters no matter no
matter what happens in life so now does
the cookout keep going absolutely okay
sticking together it seems like all
y'all want an invite yeah i do want it
in place guess who's paying you are
yeah
okay
yeah all right xavier thank you very
much and congratulations i hope you get
that money soon cbs